the cia is doubling down on its woke
advertising
got a lot of criticism for the last one
you know the woman bragging about being
a cisgender millennial with
with anxiety disorder and talking about
you know all the different identity
boxes that she
checks and see how he got criticized for
that but they don't care
and here's the latest advertisement that
they just put out a couple days ago
as an agency librarian i work to ensure
that our collection and services are
matched up with what cia
needs not only am i involved in the
acquisitions of journals
books and countless electronic resources
i'm also encouraged to curate special
collections that challenge expectation
recently i brought in our intelligence
gaming collection to give officers
unique opportunities to practice skills
they need in their various roles
instead of sitting for hours in front of
a computer-based training
they can play a carefully selected game
to train a specific set of skills
while simultaneously building on the
myriad soft skills essential to
intelligence work
my favorite thing about cia is that they
encourage the out of the box ideas that
drive real progress
growing up gay in a small southern town
i was lucky to have a wonderful and
accepting family
i always struggled with the idea that i
might not be able to discuss my personal
life at work
imagine my surprise when i was taking my
oath at cia
and i noticed a rainbow on then director
brennan's lanyard which i later learned
was designed by engel
one of the many employee resource groups
here at the agency i remember being
stunned
since then however i've learned that far
beyond the resource groups
inclusion is a core value here officers
from the top down work hard to ensure
that every single person
whatever their gender gender identity
race
disability or sexual orientation can
bring their entire self to work
every day nothing to be worried about
there just the cia
now um spending their times spending
their time
at work in a rainbow pin
playing preschool games
that's what that's apparently what cia
agents do now at work they sit down
to build their critical thinking skills
or whatever they play video games and
little preschool games rubik's cubes
um that's the cia now and and you know
it's it's very important that
uh we we allow cia
agents on the job to discuss their
personal life to talk about their sexual
proclivities
their gender identity very very
important
and it is it's important to the left
it's not just important it's the whole
point of everything
the left does not recognize that
anything has a purpose or function
beyond
advancing its ideas it's world view
it it sees that as the primary function
of everything and everyone and
especially of every institution
so the cia yes the family unit yes
that's the primary function of
everything so this isn't this isn't
going to change
but it does show you um
just how deep the leftist rot
is in our country and in our
institutions
this stuff is embedded deep in there
and leftists have been working towards
this goal give them some credit
they've been working towards this goal
relentlessly and ruthlessly
and and sort of brilliantly
um for decades this is not happening by
accident
it's not like everyone woke up yesterday
and went insane
and next thing you know the cia they're
wearing rainbow pins and playing you
know
playing video games on the job talking
about their gender identity and their
gender expression
that's not it may seem like that to
those of us who haven't been paying
attention
but uh no this this is very intentional
it's a process that's been happening
for many many years and that's why
undoing it and getting rid of the rot
revitalizing our our culture reclaiming
our culture
that is not going to be you know
a one two three step solution or just
flipping a switch or something it's not
to happen that way
and it's also a problem
that goes way beyond simply electing
republicans to fix
republicans who have shown no interest
in fixing any of this
um have really been a part of this
problem at best have done
nothing to stop it and at worst have
have taken part in
this process um
but that's why conservatives need to get
out of this
this way of thinking where it always
comes down to elections and we just got
to get a republican in the white house
and that's all that matters
this it achieves nothing if that's all
if we're for only that's that's surface
level
you're only focused at the very very top
[Music]
but as i said this rot goes deep way
deeper than that
listen hit that subscribe button right
now do it right now
i thank you for your compliance it is
somewhat appreciated